[Music]
my mom Susan Kramer was born in 1949 in
Union New Jersey just outside of New
York City
her father supported this large family
by working two jobs 80 hours a week and
making less than $11,000 a year you know
like so many I think she wanted better
and she knew that she only had a shot
she saved money studied hard and stayed
driven so to save she started working
from 14 on in addition to going to
school she was studying hard as well
even though so many had the advice of
just getting married after graduation or
file into the one of few women okay
careers and those she respected all
these things they just burned her
passion she knew she won that
competitive edge by pursuing very
rigorous schooling ie and ideally but
most Ivy League's at the time were not
very accessible to women and they were
incredibly expensive
she found one exception which was
Cornell University so this is where she
knew she wanted to be headed and by the
middle of her senior year
she'd been accepted to Cornell
my mom loved Cornell it was challenging
diverse and completely invigorating but
with the academic workload she had been
unable to hold a profitable part-time
job like she had planned and by the
middle of her freshman year was
financially drained and confronted with
the reality that she may not be able to
pay for her next year she may have to
drop out and then on one of the most
serendipitous days of her life in fact
just hours after she had finally told
her friends that she's got to drop out
and disappoint her family and even more
so herself she was called to the
financial aid office for a meeting and
informed that she was the proud
recipient of a new scholarship from an
unlikely group the Tompkins Women's Club
so she learned from the aid office that
this rural group of women was comprised
of mothers and wives from a small town a
few miles down from the University this
group was not wealthy by any means but
just simply invigorated by the new tide
of women's education and they wanted to
be a part of it and though the Women's
Club knew that their contribution might
be small in comparison to others he
simply just wanted to do what they could
and for my mom
this gesture was anything but small it
was literally life-changing this
scholarship enabled me to stay at
Cornell these women did not know me at
all it was through their efforts that I
was able to finish Cornell and then go
on with my career but the momentum of
the school year had spooked my mama and
it wasn't until sometime later she even
had a moment to stop and think about
these women again get by them the con
and Phil had changed and additional
information lost my mom was never able
to track them down and she still regrets
to this day that she was unable to say
thank you
however today my mom personally funds
her own scholarship program and pays it
forward in every way she can she helps
reinforce that while hardwork is a must
sometimes you do just need a little bit
of help and her story also stands to
remind me that I can make a difference
and even perhaps a bigger difference
than I'll know because that ripple
effect of kindness is such a real thing
[Applause]
[Music]
you
Oh